Over the last 15 years I've probably hired
tens of thousands of people that I've worked
with and when you work with these different
personalities, there are a lot of things that
you can measure, but there are a lot of things
that you cannot measure, whatsoever.
And the only way you can measure this is through
seeing this person go through it and how they
respond to it.
In an interview, a person can impress you
a lot.
"Oh my gosh, I've done this, I've done that,"
and then you get to work and you realize who
the real person is.
So I'm going to talk about 10 Unmeasurable
Qualities of a Human Being in this video today.
You can pretty much create an opinion for
yourself on when you're hiring people, and
working with people, or even yourself on which
of these areas really is this person extremely
strong at.
So let me get right into it.
Ten unmeasurable.
#1 to me is heartbeat of an organization.
Let me explain what I mean by heartbeat of
an organization.
You'll get somebody in and they'll start working
and let's say they're working in a department
or an office together and you know, within
a month, two months, three months, and all
of a sudden, they become a heartbeat of the
organization.
No one knows it.
When Mario first got started [you guys know
who Mario is], when Mario first got started
with me, we had a meeting within two weeks
we had a sales meeting on Monday morning at
like 8:00 and he had only been there for two
weeks.
It was the first time he came there.
And somebody made a remark about another one
of our sales people in our office, sales managers
in our office.
So these two sales managers got into it.
Mario got up and he said, "Look, I don't know
who you are, but you just don't talk to a
lady like that."
He had only been there for two weeks.
Boom!
Immediately we found out a lot about him,
two weeks into it.
He became the heartbeat.
From thereon, everybody knew that when this
cat was around, people were protected because
he protected people.
That's a heartbeat, right?
But you don't know that right off the bat
when you're working with somebody.
If somebody can be a heartbeat of an organization.
Whenever you look at a heartbeat of a sports
team, you'll learn, somebody comes out of
nowhere when it's tough, it's playoffs, they
show up.
But you didn't know it in practice, they don't
That's heartbeat.
You won't know that part until there's time
that goes by and there are situations for
them to rise up.
#2:Vision
A lot of people talk about, "I have a very
big vision."
A grand vision.
I want to do this, I want to do that.
But they get this much success and you realize
their vision is a very small vision.
Vision takes a long time for somebody to realize
if this person has vision or not.
I've hired people who say, "Oh, long term
I want to see myself doing this with the company
and I want to run this department, I want
to do this" and then you realize they get
a little bit of money and boom, they're vision
gets smaller and smaller and smaller.
You don't see it any more.
And then there are certain people that you
may not hear anything about them and what
they say, and then one time they said something
about a vision and the next thing you know,
they're responding and delivering in a way
that they have a bigger vision than people
that have been there for six years.
Six years!
They're just constantly going to chase the
vision that they have in their lives.
You cannot measure somebody's vision, by saying,
"tell me about your vision."
#3:Desire
Desire is, I mean, if there was a mechanism
that came out that scanned people and said,
"he has desire at the highest level," or,
"this guy has no desire whatsoever," it would
save thousands, billions of hours for different
CEOs and companies to know who to work with
and who not to work with, because desire on
somebody wanting it so bad, want it SO bad.
You know, "Pat, you have no idea how bad I
want to win. . . " and then boom, one thing
happens and they quit.
"Oh, you don't know what just happened.
We had a family crisis."
What's the crisis?
"We had my 7th cousin that just got into an
accident."
Family crisis?
"Yeah, you don't understand because I had
to go and.
. . " One time, twice, and every time something
happens, they're gone for a week.
Okay?
This person doesn't have any desire.
They're just talking a big game.
Everything to them is a family crisis.
They don't have desire.
You'll learn about it when you work with them.
You work with someone and say, "This cat's
got a lot of desire as well.'
#4: Ambition
I want to move up in the company, I want to
be a leader.
I want to do this, I want to do that.
Okay, great.
We'll see.
And you realize, they're very ambitious.
They're there first thing in the morning,
they leave late, they work, nobody tells them
to stay late, they're getting things done,
they're doing stuff.
They're absolutely ambitious.
You learn about them a year, two years, three
years, four years, five years.
. . this is one of the most ambitious people
I've ever met.
And they're not slowing down.
They're not slowing down.
You can't measure someone's ambition by just
looking at them.
#5:Long-Term Thinking
A lot of people are short-term thinkers.
Most people are short-term.
If something doesn't work out for 30, 60 days,
"You know, this is not working, I'm going
to bail.
I'm going to go somewhere else."
Long-term thinking is someone who says, "I
don't know why, but I get the feeling these
guys are going places.
I don't know why, but I see that long-term
I can be a leader and I'm going to come out
here and be a big part of this organization."
Long-term thinking.
Long-term thinking there is no way in the
world you're going to know if this person
has long-term thinking or short-term thinking
until you hire the person.
Okay, next one.
Tenacity/thick skin, right?
You'll hire certain people and they look good,
they're sharp, everything is good about them,
but you say the smallest challenge to them
and they're like, "Oh my gosh," and they shut
down.
Whoa.
If you are that thin skinned, what are you
going to do when the customer berates you
on a call and absolutely goes off on you.
You're going to be afraid of the phones.
Oh, thin skinned, you're not thick skinned,
we learn about you.
You're going to be soft and sensitive.
This is either not the right department for
you, or this is not the right company for
you.
Or you got to work on becoming thicker skinned
and become the stronger leader.
But we have to do one of those three, right?
You'll learn about that with time with people.
Next is loyalty.
Loyalty is purely time.
All these things take time.
Every single one of these takes time to realize
who's loyal and who's not.
You realize who's in it just for them and
who's in it for the entire organization.
Loyalty to me is a very big thing because
it doesn't take thousands of people to create
a major, major movement.
It takes a handful of people that are absolutely
loyal to you who are ambitious, driven, desire,
big thinkers, big vision, long-term thinking,
that have bought into what you want to do,
that are willing to do whatever they can to
run through the wall for this cause to become
a reality, for you to build a massive conglomerate
for yourself.
But it does take finding the right loyal people.
#8: Creativity
"I'm very creative.
I'm an artist.
I've been painting all my life.
I'm about music.
I'm about this.
. . " Okay, great.
Then you have an innovation meeting together
to come up with ideas.
"What ideas do you have?"
"Umm.
. . have you guys thought about putting up
a box."
Put up a box?
Yeah, what if we put up a box?"
What do you mean put up a box?
Have you guys thought about doing such and
such to the website?
It's like a bland idea.
And you sit there and after one, two, three,
four meetings and there are no ideas.
This person is not creative.
You are not creative.
It takes time to find out who is creative
or not.
Point #9 is how competitive they are.
You hear a lot of people who say, "I'm very
competitive.
I want to move up.
I'm very, very competitive.
I'm the most competitive person I know."
And then you bring them in and they're really
not that competitive.
If they lose, they're okay with it.
They lose twice, they're okay with it.
They don't have this desire to come in, stay
late, show up on the weekend to want to really
improve and go back and take the weekend and
study and improve their craft.
They don't have that.
And then you have somebody that comes in that's
quiet and doesn't look like a competitor that's
absolutely competitive.
They take the weekend to improve, they come
back sharper in a meeting.
They're ready.
You see they improved.
They got better.
You can't tell if somebody is competitive
or not right off the bat.
And the last one I'll put in is hard working.
I've had a lot of people I've hired over the
years that say, "I'm the hardest working person
I know.
I'm the hardest working person I know.
I'm the hardest working person I know."
And then they can't wait to go home at 5:00.
That's not the hardest working person you
know.
There's a lot more harder working people than
you if you can't wait to go home at 5:00.
"But you know, I have to go home.
Something came up."
Okay, a second time, third time, fourth time.
Constantly.
It's Friday, I have to leave at 3:00 and then
you see them come Monday to work and their
face is so red because they went golfing the
entire time.
So all those sorts of things you see on the
hard work side and the competitive side, you
can't measure these types of things.
No matter who you hire, you can't measure.
The only way, the only thing that you have
to figure out these things where you can measure
it is time.
Time is the only thing you have when you hire
somebody to find out what their heartbeat
is, their real vision, the desire, the ambition,
how long-term thinking they are, how thick-skinned
they are, tenacity, loyalty, creativity, how
competitive they are, and how hard working
you are.
The only thing you have as you are working
with them is to pay very close attention to
these areas and hopefully they have enough
tests that you can put to see if they truly
have these things.
You as a leader can test these areas to find
out [snap] yep, they have it.
[Snap] No, don't have it.
[Snap] Yes, they have it again.
This is real because three times I tested
the same area and the person has it.
And you as a leader find out about these areas
by certain tests you give them when you're
working with these folks and that's a whole
different subject that we can get on.
But anyway, That's my message to you.
If you haven't subscribed to this channel,
please do so.
If you've got any questions and comments,
feel free to comment on the bottom as well
and if you're watching this video on a completely
different website, you can always come back
to my website, PatrickBetDavid.com and subscribe
to my newsletter.
And again, thanks for watching, and comment
on the bottom.
Take care.
Bye Bye.